you're saying our daughter from the
future yep kind of stuck here now
anybody know what to do
I made a big mistake this man is hiding
in the shadows you guys beat him at
least see we're supposed to only because
the time I changed
I know in the future what happens to me
so anybody know what to do this is so
weird
god I love this place I can't believe
that's our daughter up there no I
shouldn't be here she could marty mcfly
herself out of existence she needs to be
with her parents 30 years from now not
us
now the flash all-new episodes Tuesdays
overnight on the CW hey everybody its
charlie we got a whole bunch of new
flash footage and they finally revealed
exactly what happened because of Norris
mistake so now we have a clear picture
for what she changed so we got to break
it down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's a new flash ring
giveaway I've also got details about
when we're gonna get episode 1 of titans
and new trailers that are gonna be
dropping at New York Comic Con so I'll
explain that at the end of the video so
the big thing here is that they
confirmed Nora changed the pass multiple
times causing the timeline to shift in
cicadas favor whereas previously he was
either a villain of the week or he was
one of the more minor villains they
rolled right past him on their way to
this crisis on Infinite Earths moment in
the future newspaper we see them in the
Time Vault Nora has a mobile version of
Gideon that glows purple that looks a
little bit like the ones that the
reverse-flash had when he first came
back to try and find out what time Barry
was from during season 2 that was like
season 2 episode 10 so she has like a
mobile emitter that seems like it will
eventually evolve into that version of
Gideon because remember Barry is the
person that creates Gideon so I'm
assuming that it's just evolved a little
bit by the time it's gotten to Nora's
time period the look on his face when
she gives him the flash ring - he's a
little confused because he's kind of
excited in the moment like oh wow you
know you have a spare suit that I can
wear and obviously it turns out to be
the season 1 suit but the funny thing
too is as that also reminds Barry of
reverse flashes costume ring so just
remember that all the stuff that the
reverse-flash uses the costume ring the
mobile Gideon it's all derived from
stuff that he got from Barry's tech
that's left over in his time period he
makes it much more advanced but it's all
original stuff that Barry used at one
time dur
the future is just that our version of
berry hasn't got to the point where he's
created that stuff yet
Cisco's really the person that creates a
lot of that tech because he's the
engineer so he helps come up with it
that might have something to do with his
arc this season but we might not get
into that too much in the first couple
of episodes so we'll just have to wait
and see about that but you get a little
bit of voiceover dialog from the new
version of Harrison wells who we've
actually seen on set I believe that
everyone's calling this Sherlock Wells I
think that's what Tom Cavanagh said at
Comic Con but he's got this vest on he's
got that slightly different haircut so I
think that his storyline is gonna dub
tale more with elongated bands because
they said that this season he would be
more of a detective so like he was a
private eye when we first met him during
season four he's gonna go back to doing
that during season five
so he says cicada has been hiding in the
shadows then you literally see cicada in
the shadows of all these different
disaster sites one of them in the
airplane that we see crashing earlier in
the trailer that's gonna be that big
action scene from the first episode with
Wally no idea if Wally's in episode two
or if he leaves at the end of episode
one
he's only supposed to be in three or
four episodes this season so he might be
around for the first two or three
episodes before he leaves you get a
brief look at cicadas face without the
mask on remember it's Chris Klein from
the American Pie series so you're
definitely familiar with them if you
don't immediately remember his face when
you hear his name you get a much more
well lit version of that deleted scene
from the season four finale where you
see the lightning bolt dagger get
charged with what looks like speed force
dark matter that probably has something
to do with the satellite save in the
dark matter explosion that the thinker
was trying to set off around the earth
the whole idea behind her mistake is
that yeah breaking the satellite apart
is part of that that might be what helps
supercharge cicadas powers with this
dagger but remember he would have been a
villain no matter what so at some point
he would have gotten this dagger so that
might be what happened in this moment
when Nora helped destroy this satellite
is it just sped up the process of cicada
getting more powerful it is no
coincidence that you see the remnants of
his dead child or children here around
the dagger and then they cut to the
picture of team flash that Nora's
looking at from season one like his
family is dead and
Berry's family is still alive so just
meant to remind you why it is cicada is
doing what he's doing he's motivated by
his dead children he hates all metas the
evil metas because they cause whatever
accident it was that led to his children
dying but also probably just hates bury
in team flash in general for existing
deleting to that sort of escalation
remember the particle accelerator
explosion in season one is what created
all these metas that then went on to
cause all these disasters that the flash
had to stop so remember when blackout
during season one wanted to kill
Harrison wells who was still secretly
reverse-flash because he caused the
explosion that led to the death of all
the people that he cared about is the
same kind of thing with cicada and then
of course Berry asked the question of
all questions the one that you're never
supposed to ask what happens to me in
the future probably a reference to what
happens with cicada in the media future
because doors like what you guys were
supposed to beat him and apparently he
beats you guys now because of what I
changed and it's also a reference to the
future newspaper flash vanishes in
crisis what happens to me why do I
disappear why have I been staring at
this newspaper for the past five years
the thing about that future newspaper is
that it's the Central City citizen
that's gonna start as irises blog this
season like you see her staring at this
photo of the wreckage and you - she kind
of picks out cicadas standing in the
background during that montage when they
talk about him standing in the shadows
so she's gonna grow the blog into a
dominant news organization in the city
so that by the time she writes this
future newspaper article buried
disappearing she becomes like the Lois
Lane or the Perry White of News in
Central City so this sort of what her
arc is gonna be about in addition to all
this family stuff that's going on with
Nora coming back from the future in the
drama between them like finding out why
it is that Nora isn't so hot on iris but
loves Barry so much I think the idea is
is the berry is dead in the future so
Nora is just really excited to meet her
hero who she hasn't really known that
well growing up only heard stories about
and then of course there's all the
killer frost stuff there's not a lot of
her in the trailer with the person that
they just cast as her father who turns
out might wind up being icicle from the
comics
even though those two characters aren't
related in the comics they might be
bringing them together I've got a lot of
questions too about Kaitlyn's dead
brother from earth-2 who's also named
Charlie just like me but he didn't exist
on earth one so who knows what
flashpoint changed they might introduce
the idea of a dead brother just because
when we started talking about icicle
people were like wait a minute are they
gonna do icicle jr. as Kaitlyn's little
brother that died but I haven't heard
anything about that as far as I know
it's just gonna be Kaitlyn her mother
who we've already met in previous
seasons in her father who's gonna be new
to the show and what's happening is is
New York Comic Con is the week before
that they're dropping a daredevil season
3 trailer Titans is gonna have its world
premiere there'll be another trailer for
that so on Wednesday the 3rd all drop my
Titans non-spoilery episode 1 review and
just let everybody know what I think of
it in general but they're not gonna have
any original shows until October 12th
that Friday is when Titans officially
premieres it'll be a Friday night show
and I'll just do as many videos as
people want I'll at least do character
videos but if everybody hates the series
then I'm not gonna do weekly videos for
it but if people think it's pretty cool
then I'll make more so we'll just see
how it goes with that
so flash Tuesday's Titans Fridays arrow
on Mondays so I'll just remind people
about the schedule as we do more videos
I'll name a new giveaway winner when I
post new DC there's new Captain Marvel
that's dropping later this morning so
that'll be my next video click here to
learn all about Henry Cavill becoming
geralt of the witcher series on Netflix
which is crazy and click here for brand
new Captain Marvel thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]